okay
here we are
today we're going to look at trees and
lots of trees we're going to look at
decision trees and then
later on we're going to look at random
forests
and we're going to see how to fit these
in r
and just as before we're using our
studio
and so here we are we've got an r studio
session and we're going to use our
markdown
and
we'll start off by just getting our
packages loaded including the tree
package which you need to load
and we're going to start off with the
car seats data
so we've got all those loaded
and let's just have a look at our data
we'll look at the
histogram of of
sales and we see sales is a quantitative
variable
i want to demonstrate using trees with a
with a binary response so we'll turn
sales into a binary variable which we'll
create called high
and you'll see there if else sales is
less than eight
we'll say it's
the it's not high so the sales are not
high otherwise yes so that if else is a
handy construct
okay
and and now we'll put high back onto our
data frame which we can just use with
the data frame command and it's smart
enough it sees car seats as a data frame
it's already got some variables that
includes a variable high on it
so there we're done
and so now we created a binary variable
and now we're going to fill a model
using trees
now of course we can't leave sales if
we're going to use the dot notation as
we have before
we have to exclude sales because
the the our response here high was
created from sales so you can put a
minus sign in a formula so we got high
twiddle dot minus sales
so that means model high as a function
of everything except sales you've taken
sales out and you can subtract other
variables out the formula as well so
it's just a handy way of doing it
and
so we fit the tree and now we we do a
summary
and underneath and we see the summary
below there
we see the variables that we involved
number of terminal nodes
um residual mean deviance which in this
case is
um
[Music]
yeah it's a binary response so it's a
binomial deviance
and we can plot the tree which we do
and you get a
plot of a binary tree you see all the
terminal nodes and you can annotate it
with a command text which is very handy
now on the
in this picture here the the font is
bigger i made the font big enough so
that you could see it
of course
what that means is you can't actually
see all the details but there's so many
variables there's so many splits in this
tree that it's a complex tree to to to
to look at so we wouldn't really learn a
huge amount from this tree and what you
do see is that each of the terminal
nodes so if we look down here at the
terminal nodes they're labeled yes or no
and
and each of the splitting variables is
labeled at the place where the split
took place and
at which value of that variable the
split
occurred
and then by the time you get to a
terminal node the
the the vote goes the label is according
to the majority of the yeses or no's in
this case that are in the terminal node
okay so that's
that's we've grown a tree and we've
plotted it
this tree is a little bit big so
we're gonna
we're gonna see how we can prune it down
you can look at a detailed version of
the tree which we do by just printing
and so we type tree
and you'll see here
we've got
a printout
which basically gives the details of
every single terminal node
so
the root it tells you how many
observations at the root what's the the
mean deviance at the root
and uh
and then
for every single splitting variable
it
and this is a proportion of yeses and
no's at the root therefore every single
node is numbered and you can see if you
can see how the numbering works by
by
going down the tree and it gives you
details of every node in the tree so
that's handy especially if you want to
extract
the details from the tree for
you know
for other purposes
okay
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to create a training we're going
to split our car seats data into
training and test set so we'll make it
250 to 150 there's 400 observations in
all
and
as as we often do we'll set the seed
just to to make our results reproducible
i i make a habit of never always setting
the same seeds i i jump around use
different seeds which is not a bad idea
and and then we sample from the we we're
gonna we're gonna take a random sample
of the of the id numbers of the samples
the index numbers of the samples so we
sample from the set 1 to n row number of
rows of car seats which is 400 we know
that and we want a sample of size 250
default by default sample uses with
replacement
without replacement i should say
and and so now we got this index ed
train which indexes 250 of the
400 observations
so now we can refit our model using tree
same formula
except we tell a tree to use a subset
equals train so it will just use that
subset
and when we
make the plot
the plot
looks seems to look a little bit
different of course it's a slightly
different data set the the complexity of
the tree looks roughly the same
and so now
we're going to what we're going to do is
take this big bushy tree and predict it
on the
on the
test set
which and we use the predict method for
trees
um
[Music]
and so there we go tree dot pred gets
predict
we give it the fitted tree tree.car
seats and then we give it the data on
which we want to predict
now we want to use the test data so
that's the data frame car seats
indexed with minus train so we want to
remove the the training observations
which will of course leave the test
observations and then we also tell a
type equals class
because you can make different types of
predictions in particular you can
predict the probabilities here we want
to actually predict the class labels
and so we do that and now we want to
evaluate the error
and so here i use the width command
again so
with car seats
minus train so that's with the test data
this is a handy way of of just
assigning a data frame
as the context in which to do the next
command and the next command is table
the tree dot pred which we just computed
which is the classification on the test
data and the variable hi which is going
to be in that
that test data set
so there we get a little um
misclassification table
on the diagonals are the correct
classifications on the off diagonals or
the of or the incorrect classifications
so here we'll just record the correct so
we'll take the sum of the two diagonals
divided by the total which is 150 year
and we see that we get a an error rate
of 0.7 with this this big bushy tree
so we know that
when we grow a bushy tree it could have
too much variance and so now we're going
to use cross validation to prune the
tree optimally
and so we do that using cv.tree and we
tell it that we want to use
misclassification error as the basis for
doing the pruning
so this will do 10-fold cross-validation
for us
and
we can
we can print out the results it was very
quick
and it tells you
the
some details of the path of the cross
validation so it tells you this the size
of the trees as they were pruned back
tells you the deviance as the prunion
proceeded and notice the deviant drops
down and then
it seems to increase
and
it tells you what the cost complexity
parameter was in in the process
now you can actually plot this guy
and so if we plot it we see this kind of
jumpy because it's misclassification
error on only 100
on on 250
cross-validated points so it's somewhat
jumpy
but we see it does seem to bottom out
before it it increases
so let's pick a value down near the
minimum so we'll pick 13 which is
somewhere in the middle and we'll prune
our tree
to
to a size of 13 to find identify that
tree now this is the tree fit on the
full training data
okay
and we can plot that tree and and
annotate it as well
so it's a little bit shallower than the
the previous uh
trees and now we can actually read the
labels
um and so that's the result of of
validation
and now we can evaluate it on our test
data set again so this is just a repeat
of the commands we had before we get a
table it doesn't look much different
actually and in fact it seems like the
the correct classifications dropped a
little bit but it's probably just one
observation so we didn't get too much
from pruning except we got a shallower
tree which is is easier to interpret
so
so that's using trees trees are very
handy especially if you get shallow
trees they they nice to interpret you
can
you know you can describe them to people
you can see exactly what's going on
um often case trees don't give very good
prediction errors so in the next session
we're going to look at random forests
and boosting which tend to outperform
trees as far as
as prediction and misclassification
errors are concerned